hi I'm Neil Patrick Harris and I am
about to go undercover on the Internet
this is actually me nice computer by the
way GQ first question comes from quarrel
what are the anti-aging products taken
by Neil Patrick Harris here's the key
moisturize moisturize moisturize just
because you're a dude doesn't mean you
have to be off roof or ah and not put
lotion on your face parts and then drink
copious amounts of blood submitted how
does Neil Patrick Harris feel about
kissing girls on How I Met Your Mother
given these yay okay I added my own
inflection let me try that again
less judgy how does Neil Patrick Harris
feel about kissing girls on How I Met
Your Mother
given these gay kissing girls is super
fun they're pretty their skin is soft
and when they slip you in a tongue hello
I did one scene where I kissed a girl
she was 85 years old it'd been a while I
guess cuz she went for it
when did the cast of How I Met Your
Mother learned the details of the series
finale the Christmas party of season 8 I
cornered Carter and Craig my bosses the
creators and executive producers at Kim
Miam in a very drunken stupor forced
them to tell me the the end and they did
and I loved it and I appreciated it and
it makes me rewash the episodes with a
newfound lens of appreciation Yahoo
Answers yeah is there a film where Neil
Patrick Harris cries or a video why I'm
not one of these actor people that can
just give the clenchy jaw tear
I'm blotchy and puffing and do the goat
cry ever except my husband described the
body type of Neil Patrick Harris live
lean large
how would I style my hair like Neil
Patrick Harris okay
takes a long time you need to pomade
need the conditioner get a flat iron you
need a jheri curl then you need the leak
tape then you need that black powder
stuff takes out the you know after that
what do we do just in the blow-dry so
you need to brush the curling brush and
then you wet it all and just go like
this and you're done
there you go Twitter you brought are you
Twitter why is hashtag Neil Patrick
Harris that a thing managing this
holiday in in Borough that manager is
disarmingly attractive his name is Marc
winter by the way I'm more of a
spring/summer his Neil Patrick Harris on
this episode of friends never been on
friends though I do love monkeys YouTube
you will be swelled
you'll be great where can i buy Neil
Patrick where's his album seriously he
should have continued his music career
too after dr. horrible because I'll tell
you why I feel so bad for the people
there in a certain head space right and
they record this album of angst about
their breakup then a year later they
released the album and for a year after
that they have to sing that same breakup
album all the time on Good Morning
America at 7 a.m. I feel like that would
be exhausting and no fun then again
Donald Glover is doing it really well
Neil is my spirit animal I would be way
more flattered if it spelled my name
correctly
I am dB
trademarks often plays mischievous
characters often works his singing
abilities into roles often worked his
abilities as an illusionist into his
roles hilariously it's all I got
confirmed reddit yes I have
I was rating them to post their yearly
Halloween picture here are some previous
ones and one more we love a good family
Halloween picture always have but now we
just have to convince opinionated 7 year
olds that what we want is the right way
to dress which is increasingly difficult
because they bruise so easily
Wikipedia 2014 Eris turned down the
chance to replace David Letterman in
that role he also rejected the
suggestion of replacing Craig Ferguson
as host of The Late Late Show on the
same grounds well that makes it sound
like I would straight-up offer to gig
that wasn't true but I was on a CBS show
and that was certainly conversations
that were questioning my interest in a
talk show realm he attended La Cueva
high school in Albuquerque graduating
with high honors in 1991 I did graduate
from La Cueva high school go bears
with high honors oh I did okay I mean
half the euro is tutored on a set by a
teacher who you know fed me the specific
information that I needed to solve tests
more hora what is the most badass thing
about Neil Patrick Harris hey hey hey my
ass is far from bad easy bang nailed
that comedy in what time slash IRRI is a
series of unfortunate events set it's
intentionally an era less show we want
it to not be modern so they can't go on
line or have a cellphone but we don't
want to be old-timey so they have to
talk like that from the the 40s see what
will happen if Neil Patrick Harris
becomes governor of New Mexico not gonna
happen not again did politics is not my
jam hole I follow it a little bit
I have my own opinions I'm a jester in
this fair court we call the game of
Thrones
why didn't the old Patrick Harris decide
to buy a house in Harlem we've lived in
Harlem New York for a long time I think
it's awesome I love the history of it I
love the people that are there and
there's great hearts there and great
food there got nothing bad to say about
Harlem digitised there's some answers to
some of your hard-hitting questions I'm
tired of hearing my own voice so case
closed sorry